l'allemand soir commence
comme ça c'est content de vous avoir
avec nous ce soir jeunes ça nous fait
vraiment très plaisir je suis content
d'y remédier mais pas qu'on vous appelle
madame moreau préféré mademoiselle pas
ce que dit madame ben arous et ma mère
mais donc vous c'est plutôt mademoiselle
moreau puisque elle était mariée choisi
nanterre voilà alors vous êtes actrice
et chanteuse
vous êtes un médecin chanteuse
[Musique]
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche j'me suis
bien mais bien c'est les classiques à
céder tout le monde les connaît car ma
sympathie donc vous êtes comme je dis
actrice comédienne chanteuse
réalisatrice et maintenant metteur en
scène de théâtre puisque vous monter une
pièce à chaillot vous avez monté une
pièce et chaillot j'appelle un trait de
l'esprit qui est écrite par margaret
edson vous avez fait l'adaptation wii et
la mise en scène voilà on va faire un
petit bout c'est comment on fait je vous
avais pas montréal
petit prix comme du siam est formidable
cette grande actrice a alors le pitch de
la pièce c'est une divine béring qui est
professeur qui souffre d'un cancer en
phase terminale et vous dites dans
ballon de la pièce que c'est assez le
triomphe de l'esprit sur la matière oui
c'est à dire que c'est un raccourci
saisissant c'est une pièce qui dure 90
minutes
mais on peut se dire qu'en venant au
monde
nous avons tous un virus qui va nous
mener le temps qu'il faut peut-être 80
90 40 ça dépend jusqu'à la mort et cette
femme qui a étudié la poésie un peut
être extraordinaire qui s'appelle john
donne dont la vie a été très mouvementée
qui a commencé à être aimé des femmes et
à aimer les femmes et puis petit à petit
il a progressé vers la lumière
j'appellerais ça comme ça et qui lui a
appris le courage la lucidité
et elle fait ce chemin avec beaucoup de
lucidité d'humour et elle fait rire il
ya des gens que ça a beaucoup choqué
parce qu'ils croient que quand on
souffre on pleure tout le temps mais la
vie c'est un mélange moi il m'est arrivé
de rire comme une folle à l'enterrement
de mon père mais ça veut pas dire que je
n'étais pas triste
alors l'actrice qui joue le rôle
principal celui là michael en fait j ai
été contacté pour le rôle principal
vous pensez que ce rôle doit être tenu
par quelqu'un qui est encore en âge
d'avoir des enfants oui et donc comme ça
n'est pas mon cas j'ai tout de suite
proposé d'en faire la mise en scène j'en
ai envie tout de suite vu des mauvais
souvenirs quand vous avez voulu avoir
des enfants avec pierre cardin en 62
n'ont pas remis on n'a pas pu alors
qu'avant je tomber enceinte pour un oui
pour un non et là j'ai pensé qu'il y
avait un problème et puis j'ai fait
faire des examens et à ce moment là on a
on a vu que j'avais un cancer et on m'a
opéré mais voilà vous aviez à l'opérer
apparemment n'ai jamais eu de séquelles
avenir compliqué mais alors tout ça
m'amène à parler de vous a parlé de
votre de votre oeuvre on peut dire votre
vie votre oeuvre
la légion d'honneur pourquoi vous la
mettez un parce que mon père serait
drôlement est pas bon enfin c'est ça je
me serais un pin ce début moi je
peux arrêter anglaise parce qu'on
parlait de parler tout à l'air de donne
du poète john et vous l'avez lu très
jeune au 6e
voilà votre mère était anglaise est
venue à paris pour danser aux folies
bergères votre mère était danseuse
dk oui c'est incroyable ça et puis a
rencontré votre votre père s'appelait
paul moreau qui avait monté un
restaurant à montmartre paul moreau pour
les montmartrois mais ces réunions c'est
un atoll désiré mot à dire comme son
frère s'appelait arsène ouais j'avais
des jolis prénoms dans la famille
donc il vient il montre un restaurant à
montmartre et montrent un restaurant à
montmartre quoi vous venez souper les
artistes vient la cloche d'or voilà et
votre mère s'est retrouvée enceinte
evans est alors à la bonbonne la dance
kids assez triste quand même à
l'abandonnent la danse et finalement
elle a eu toute sa vie des regrets de ne
pas avoir été artiste non oui elle me
parlait toujours du voyage en amérique
qu'elle aurait dû faire
mais elle me l'a dit assez tardivement
quand même mais j'ai senti que j'étais
pas vraiment désiré mais après quand je
lui ai dit ce que je voulais faire alors
là elle m'a vraiment courir et oui vous
dit chez nous il s'était plaint de
dureté de chagrin pourquoi
parce que c'était c'était dur la vie
était dure mon père vient d'une famille
paysanne
moi je suis une enfant du 19e siècle en
fait vous voyez j'ai été élevé avec ses
principes j'aime pas le droit de lire
les journaux
je n'avais pas le droit de lit
mais vous lisiez sous les draps avec le
coach on a fait venir un médecin parce
que j'avais les yeux cernés parce qu'on
le soupçonnait de masturbation mais
c'était la lecture
on parlait pas beaucoup de sexualité
chez vous' été très prudent c'est à dire
qu'il y avait des sous-entendus tout le
temps pour le café tout ça et alors on
disait attendait veux-tu sortir s'il te
plaît
naturellement je m'étais derrière la
porte pour essayer d'en temps mais je
n'avais pas besoin de ça parce que dans
les livres et ça les gens qui n'aiment
pas lire ça devrait les encourager c'est
là que j'ai tout appris s'est expliqué
très très bien et je alayli
pornographiques un des livres
dans le bruit des lacets la culotte qui
tombe et frémissements les battements du
coeur
toute l'émotion lui qui lui saute dessus
dans une calèche c'est magnifique alors
puis vous étiez exposé quand même à tous
les dangers auxquels sont exposés les
enfants il va un boulanger à côté de
chez vous ça c'est un moment un moment
que tu es très pervers 1 est un cochon
est un cochon il essaie toujours de vous
toucher et vous quand vous allez voir
votre peur disait ne doit être d une
[ __ ] t'as l'esprit mal tourné
il me disait que j'étais monsieur ce que
j'étais une salade mais parce que c'est
une solidarité masculine qui existe sans
doute moins maintenant alors moment
c'était un quartier très chaud à
l'époque vendait de l'alcool sexe mâcon
se sont un peu calmées montmartre
maintenant oui mais moi n'oubliez pas
que j'ai connus montmartre au moment de
l'adolescence on me monde l'occupation
allemande alors j'ai vu des trucs
absolument dégueulasse interdit aux
[ __ ] interdit aux juifs
j'ai vu des gens se vendre pour 1 kilo
de beurre et
mais vraiment des gens qui faisait
n'importe quoi pour gagner du pognon et
d'autres pour se nourrir alors quand
vous connaissez pas grand chose de la
vie enfin vous attendez à la découvrir
vous vous dites que les adultes c'est
vraiment pas
jolie vous découvrez le théâtre allant
voir mary bale la comédie française
c'est bien antigone d'abord oui antigone
avec qui dans le rôle avec monel
valentin ah bon vous ignorez tout d'elle
tout à fait puisque les maribel la
circulation sur un tueur la porte et
antigone la résistance ça ça oui je
résiste et puy mary bale dans phèdre la
passion amoureuse pour son gendre ça ça
doit vous a marqué ça ça a été décisif
pour votre vocation ça mais là vous avez
dit je vais être comédienne ouais et
alors vous avez de la chance parce que
vous avez eue denis d'inès qui était le
doyen la colonie française comme prof
plein beaucoup de chance un type très
très sévère jamais demandé plus sévère
puisque mon père était contre alors je
voulais être vraiment être sûr que je
pouvais tenir le coup et lui il a été
épatant parce que comme je n'ai pas de
sous il m'a fait travailler pour rien et
il m'a préparé vous a préparé au
conservatoire gratuitement
et que votre père quand il a vu ça
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait quand il a vu
autant de dernière j'étais déjà actrice
il a vu ma photo en première page de
france soir oui bottemer effet retourner
en angleterre
avec votre petite soeur vous étiez resté
avec votre père qui d'ailleurs à part
des espoirs piccola un peu trop et le
jour il a vu la photo vous a viré à
coups de pieds au cul ouais c'est pas ça
rigolait oui ça rigolait pas du tout
alors à priver vous voir quand même un
de temps en temps au théâtre ah ben oui
mais il était aux 1er 2e rei dormait
alors les acteurs qui allait en cause
ici disais merde ya un type qui
c'est un budget diop c'était mon père il
dort même avant de dormir elysées c'est
ma fille s'est elle ne sait pas qui
dormait sur tous et qui ronflait un
ouais et alors quand ils voyaient jeanne
faire des films il disait tu te laisse
embrasser par gabin ce vieux dégueulasse
tomber ça ça pourrait être mon père mais
vous avez qu'on en parle malin mais je
n'adore way de votre père ben oui oui
nema services à des maisons côté jury
bah oui parce que moi vous êtes rebeller
contre quelque chose de laid quelque
chose contre moi il était très beau
c'est la prochaine fois je mangerai il
vous donnez lui un bouton et de l'ue
j'ai pas la bouche c'est qu'ils me faire
votre mère nina mieux avant c'est une
bouche extraterrestres
et la voix ah non deux qui personne une
voix extraterrestre
bon on va parler des autres hommes de ma
vie parce qu'on va faire des soirées sur
votre père quand même voilà les hommes
de la vie de jeanne moreau a déjà eu des
demandes
je mélange tout moi un jour vous
découvrez que vous êtes enceinte de
votre premier amour qui s'appelait jean
louis richard hein vous aviez 20 ans et
vous vous preniez la grossesse communes
comme une punition dans la grossesse
gelé très bien vécu
mais après c'est l'idée d'avoir un bébé
vous plaisait pas ça je n'ai pas envie
donc cette année en suisse pour vous
faire avorter et vous n'avez pas fait
l'idée de retard c'est être au coeur
alors vous rend triste mais si moi j'ai
pensé le séjour oui et lorsque très
bizarre si vous partez en suisse et vous
revenez à paris et vous tombez dans le
métro complètement par hasard sur le
père de l'enfant voilà j'en lever les
charges années perdues dié et qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait vous emmener dans sa
famille oui vous faire à côté d'une
copine elle a des problèmes elle sait
pas où loger à bombay et puis je veux
via mois deux mois et on se disait on
chuchotait on dormait dans la
bibliothèque comment on va faire pour
leur annoncer
j écoute on va acheter de la naine de
les y ait des aiguilles à tricoter
vivait commencé à tricoter puis je vais
laisser traîner ça ils vont comprendre
ouais ça a été le fou rire qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et ce même s'il a accouché
la veille de votre mariage c'est fort
non le lendemain le lendemain au
lendemain du mariage non j'étais au
cinéma la veille vous n'étiez pas très
attendri par là par la naissance de
votre enfant parce que vous téléphoner
aussitôt à votre metteur en scène jean
mane et j'étais fier très fier mais vous
le dire que c'est près de travail dans
dix jours devant lui j'ai mis deux
heures à accoucher ouais j'ai téléphoné
à 6h10
merveille on sait jamais quoi dire aux
gens qu'on a envie de réveiller à 6
heures du matin c'était pas mal quand
même
ça y est j'ai un fils j'ai embauché deux
heures vous avez jamais été une mère
très attentionné quand même maintenant
je suis
en fait ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
passé c'est que quand votre fils a eu
son accident de voiture avec belmondo un
jour c'était le tournage de quel film
moderato
cantala et donc belmondo prend une
dauphine gordini qui était la même la
vôtre que je ne conduisais pas tout
n'avait lui il avait son permis depuis
juin il embarque jérôme donc le fils de
jeanne ils ont un accident il passe ses
jours 17h09 ah et là vous commencez
quand même à vous dire à vous intéresser
un peu plus chez lui mais non mais j'ai
toujours aimé tendrement
non j'essaie de vous faire passer pour
la toute fin de prêt j'essaie de faire
de vous un portrait le portrait
comme si on était osé six jeunes et non
mais maintenant il va très bien il faut
dire les choses il vit en californie
sympa
et à paris
est revenue d'accord mais oui donc vous
n'avez pas été une mère très attentionné
vous êtes une grande amoureuse quand
même et vous avez connu beaucoup
d'hommes orson welles c'est vrai qu'il
voulait que vous quittiez tout pour le
suivent en amérique
c'est pas vrai
là c'est pas vrai qu'elle bourg or sept
ans mais déjà après il m'a dit j'étais
amoureux fou de toi je n'étais pas à
perdre avant et vous l'aviez après oui
et moi on m'a dit qu'il était prêt à
payer le dédit de la comédie française
pour vous le suivrez la cage à thoune
année qui m'a mis d'accord pour que je
couche jamais ah ouais d'accord qu'il
n'avait pas osé vous dire que j'étais
amoureux de vous après après vient après
vous avez fait trois films avec lui oui
c'est falstaff le procès plein procès et
puis soirée martin voilà c'est ça donc
après louis malle les amants en et saint
louis malle jamais prétendre aux plus
grands de montlouis mahb oui un des way
un délai ne vous aurais jamais fait les
allemands comme ça si vous n'aviez pas
été ensemble ça se sent votre envoi de
films en
peut-être peut-être vous sentir en
faisant le film que ça allait vers la
fin que le fait de faire ce film revient
sur bien sûr je sentais que je voudrais
passer quelque chose et que
je jouais en accéléré
la faim de m de notre relation s'est
brûlé votre relation avec lui dans ce
film oui vous avez tourné avec brigitte
bardot s'est pas très bien passé non si
j'aime entendre à moi ce qu'on l'a
raconté je vous assure que ça s'est très
très bien passé
je ne veux pas vous contredire là mais
c'est ce que coûterait 10 brigitte est
quelqu'un de magnifique et qui n'a
jamais aimé être comédienne à la barbe
donc elle est pas leur
salle énerve un site où j'ai pas là il
ya une panne de courant vous dire si
c'est vrai il ya une panne de courant
sur le tournage de de viva maria donc le
petit fan de pareils et elle a dit si on
trouve jeunes assassinés ce sera pas la
peine de chercher bien loin l'assassin
oui ben là 10
avril truffaut n'arrête pas réussi vous
eu une aventure avec truffaut non
l'amitié amoureuse une amitié amoureuse
avant qardaoui olympiens oui car grâce
et c'est mademoiselle chanel qui vous a
dit un jour j'ai pas le temps de
m'occuper de toi ouais vous citez moi le
film avec les eva eva à il m'a dit allez
voir ce jeune est qu'il fait des très
beaux vêtements et j'ai vu vraiment je
suis tombée folle le petit curieux en
tout le monde parle et ça a duré quatre
ans quoi moi ça va plus le pierre cardin
et à mesure ouais tout le monde quoi je
m'appelais pierre cardin
et alors après le bouquet alors là je
suis là c'est le bouquet c'est le
réalisateur de l'exorciste et de french
connection william friedkin alors lui
quand je vais demander qu'on vous
demande pourquoi vous l'avait épousée
vous dites c'est le seul qui m'a demandé
en mariage celle ci vous étiez
bouleversé ah oui ça m'a ému c'était
dans une boîte de nuit en nuit ya oui et
vous a demandé en mariage je n'ai pas pu
vais craquer j'ai dit oui ça m'a paru
bien voilà
le problème c'est que vous ne dirigez
votre carrière qua non à partir du
moment où il m'a épousé si j'étais
malade friedkin ouais ben alaoui de
guînes c'était sa maman
exactement alors il a commencé à bloquer
mon imprésario l'a dit non non ils
disaient tous les scénarios moi on me
les donnaient même pas lire et ils
disaient ah non madame friedkin ne
tourne pas sale madame frites qui ne
tourne pas avec machin madame frime
keane alors j'ai dit bon vous avez
divorce et c'est à vous que le divorce a
coûté du pognon oui c'est incroyable ça
c'est une époque je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'argent ça ok aucun souvent c'est une
époque assez bizarre parce que vous
passiez de festival en festival où elle
s il est pas con a commencé à me rendre
des hommages alors j'avais des
garde-robes somptueux c'est très bon
bagage je voyageais en première d'un
hôtel sublim et puis si je voulais faire
une course et prend un taxi j'avais pas
de quoi vous habitez ou g a quitté alors
louis avait un appartement vide
j'habitais chez lui j'ai une autre amie
qui ma loge et
francine racette d'un alsa dans
l'emballage est ce à cause des impôts
tout ça donc à causer wii et plus
vraiment d'ivoire d'alors ça coûte cher
mais qu'on divorce moi ça a coûté cher à
toi je tiens le jour où elles vivent un
tiers votre cas si vous dites jeanne
vous dites j'ai eu beaucoup même dans ma
vie mais je pense pas avoir aimé un
homme comme un peu non j'ai dire aimer
aimer je pense l'amour l'amour parfait
l'amour magnifique l'amour sans
sans intérêt l'amour amour absolu
l'amour absolu je t'aime mais tu veux
être loin de moi parce que tu es plus
heureux plus heureuse sans moi très bien
ce qui compte c'est que tu sois heureuse
mais
[Musique]
heureusement merci
alors vous savez les jeunes qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle ah oui là
non mais vous allez voir on embauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
il est long et une guerre plus en plus à
une rallonge si bien alors ça s'appelle
l'interview alerte aux roses c'est tombé
sur vos aïeux quelle est votre première
pensée jeunes moreau lorsque vous
trouvez qu'un homme est séduisant salut
jeunes
ça va toi langage vous engager est-ce
que préféré draguer ou vous faire
draguer
et guay l'étude embrassez vous faire
embrasser en ligue 1 les trains en même
temps caressé ou vous faire caresser
pareil de larguer ou faire larguer
garnier la galerie bleue
qu'elle ou non
quel est pour vous le lieu idéal pour
une étreinte l'été
à l'ombre
l'hiver au chaud
quel est le lieu où vous seriez
incapable de faire l'amour le space
mountain près d'une poubelle a prévu une
poubelle est-ce que vous avez besoin
d'aimer pour faire l'amour de faire
l'amour pour aimer
ça dépend des relations des fois ça
commence ça peut commencer par le sexe
et venir de l'amour oui
est ce que vous préférez attention c'est
très grave ça mais un mec qui bosse bien
mais qu'un fidèle ou un mec lieberman
mais qui est fidèle ni l'un ni l'autre
ah bon je recherche un troisième oui ses
fidèles
m
[Applaudissements]
alors au sujet si j'ai de l'adultère est
ce que vous préférez pas savoir où tout
ce n'est la pas d'un dut lutter savons
que c'est un mot à la fin du 19e siècle
c'est existe plusieurs liaisons préfère
le mot liaison non ça va ça vient tout
ça abonde actuellement oui tu te sens
donc voilà donc on n'en parle même pas
mais on en parle c'est pas n'existe pas
mais on a ce culte heures c'est un tel
cliché ya deux ans qu'ils foutent leur
relation alain pour ça ça vaut pas la
peine d'inventer un nouveau mot pour ça
je sais pas on n'en parle pas c'est tout
non non pas par la réponse est ce que
vous conservez dernière question un
fantasme non réalisés mais d'état ah oui
vous pensez les réaliser non justement
ça va pas ah ouais vous pensez que les
banques à penser que c'est plus excitant
de paris vibrer
c'est selena thénia mais une fois que
c'est fait c'est fait
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux